joe ross in his career ninth game
seventh start against philadelphia 28
years old six four two twenty last start
july 31st against the cubs received the
six to three loss
this one to right yadiel to his right
routine fly ball to start the day
first pitch from ross swung on him
popped up right center field soto moving
in now back to his left a bit and he
makes the catch for the island muto is
retired on a fly
to soto and right on one pitch
another line drive from harper and role
plays in and to his right a loud first
inning three fly ball outs aaron nola
making his 20-second start on the year
fastball which he'll use a sinker off of
it curveball in a changeup 529 era on
the road he's been able to command his
fastball both sides of the plate
breaks his bat hits that one over the
second base bag the reyes throws him out
and one out here in the first
swing at a miss
ben you wanted him to spin the baseball
he just spun it beautifully there that's
the first strikeout for nola two outs
for juan soto
and a strike three called a little help
by the umpire
and that's back-to-back strikeouts for
nola
as he sets the nationals down in order
here in the first here's reese hoskins
leading off in inning number two
other way and under the glove of a
slow-footed josh bell
and hoskins is a board with a lead-off
single here in the second two strikes
just put it in play
swing and a miss joe ross getting two
consecutive hitters 0-2
that's a pretty easy take for herrera
two on two out and down to ronald
torreira's the number eight hitter
mr reyes browns one toward the middle
base in it to center field rounding
third as reece hoskins he'll score
robles had trouble getting it out of his
glove the phillies take the early lead
it's one nothing here in the seconds
row toe
dusty watson sent him here but
you got aaron nola coming up must might
as well take a shot at it
that's nasty on the inside edge
ross three strikeouts in the inning but
the billy's two singles around to walk
one nothing one away brings up yadiel
hernandez and nola drops one to the
bottom of his bat then drops the ball to
the ground then throws it away and
hernandez and hoskins
just
heavily collide at the back
hoskins reaching across for the throw
hernandez steaming down the line
and that was some hard contact
so it looks like everyone's okay
now they all stay in the game rhys
hoskins is
oh
okay and that was that was ugly no hard
feelings hey man sorry that's just
baseball you all right yeah i'm all
right
that wasn't their fault chris harper
line to center field his first
at-bat
and he hits that one out towards center
field roble's going back it is gone
number 250 rolling up the hill
bryce harper has given the films a
two-nothing lead with a solo home run
to straight away center field what a
swing very fitting he gets number 250
in the nation's capital
how about it 427 feet and it's a
beautiful swing again they tried to go
in what a powerful swing there's alec
boom joe ross struck him out first time
ross into his wind-up deals and a swing
and a miss he blew balm away with a high
fastball second time he's done that and
baum who was strikeout victim number two
is strikeout victim number six
so a broken bat to strike out and that
was career number 400 for joe ross
well done joe bottom of the fourth soto
bell and hernandez the wind in the pitch
way outside on a curveball and soto
draws his league leading 77th walk
and this one right side well placed
juan soto is going to
check it out and roll the third harper's
throw late
good base running by juan soto
and a corner situation with nobody out
and that's gonna be an rbi single to
left
carter kibum is two for two
and he's now 11 for his last 25 easily
his best stretch of hitting at the major
league level yeah you're going to pound
me in i'll get you out of there and
they'll elevate too
the two-seam fastball
just off the sweet spot
low
good at bad faces loaded one eye
oh and it hit him
it sounded like maybe got him on the
elbow guard
and how about that for a way to tie the
game it's an rbi the hard way
and the wheels are coming off for erin
nola here in the fourth
swag and a miss he got him with a change
up
seven strikeouts for nola
eight men come to the plate in the
inning two score it's two on with nobody
out for josh bell
that ball is crushed
right center
think big indeed
see
you
later and it's five to two hello 60 rbis
good call great swing
19th homer of the year and just like
that it's five to two nets
that was a low missile so it's five six
seven gregorius bowman herrera to one
pitch swinging a long drive right field
soto drifting back racing toward the
track he's near the wall he leaps and he
caught it
he robs gregorius of a home run at the
bullpen fence
soto showing the bonus glove for all the
world to see
one of the best plays juan soto's made
in his big league career in the outfield
he robs gregorio so the four bagger at
the right field fence and the crowd
salutes juan soto's defensive gem well
that was outstanding he got back there
to set up felt for the wall and took a
home run away with the glove over the
top of the bullpen fence
alec balm out to left center field
row blaze won't get that one it's going
to be off the base of the wall he plays
it well his throw into second not in
time oh one out double duple herrera is
due up for the phillies
double grounds it through the hole in
the left side of base hit bombs around
third heading for home he's going to
score
and the phillies are within two they
bring the tying run to the plate it's an
rbi for o'dubo herrera it's a 5-3 game
too odd with two outs in a two-run game
ground ball toward the middle diving
stopped to raise throws to second not in
time dede throws home and he is out at
home what a play
what a play all the way around dede
gregorius somehow threw one that hugged
the ground and jt real mutual was able
to apply the tag and the inning is over
ninth inning here at nationals park
nationals go to the bullpen for
right-hander kyle finnegan to try and
close this one out with a two-run lead
yeah the one two
in the air out toward right center field
robles on the run he's not gonna get
there it's gonna be off the top of the
wall why did that carry oh doubles on
his way to second he's there standing
and stumbling
and the fills will bring the tying run
to the plate i hope he's okay he tripped
over the bag oh man
he is in a lot of pain
he went into the second base bag and
just stumbled i mean it looks like he
got hurt three different times that's
exactly right
well that's a great sign that he's even
up and doing that like you said
hopefully it's just a crap shook his
head like i'm okay all right well he's
gonna stay in and it's gt coming up with
two in scoring position three balls two
strikes and the pitch
and a line drive out toward right center
field that's going to be in for an extra
base hit the game is tied herrera scores
to reyes scores jt's at second it's a
5-5 game
the phillies have tied it up here at the
top of the ninth inning do the dang
thing jt
how about it
man has he been clutching this road trip
and now they'll walk harper
intentionally yep they did that
and it'll bring rhys hoskins up with a
chance to give the phillies the lead
there's a line drive out toward left
field going back as hernandez he won't
get it
j teals score harper's speeding around
third heading home he'll score without a
throw it's a two-run double for reese
and the phillies take the lead they lead
it seven to five with two outs here in
the ninth inning they are the cardiac
kids
they have scored four runs
in this inning well it's archie bradley
who's come on to try to get the last
three outs of this game
bell up the middle it hits the bag takes
a weird hop bell is safe the ball goes
into the camera well so does juan soto
is sent home
josh bell goes to second base hold on
the nets got a break
with a redirect it appeared off the
second base bang and the 1-2 pitch to
kibu
bouncer toward the bow picked up by
bradley throws to first ball game is
over the phillies come from behind they
win it seven to six
and for the first time since the 14th of
may they're three over 500
and for the first time since the 16th of
may they're within a half game of first
place in the national league east
you